Now the cool thing about inheritance patterns of dominant recessive
traits is that it all depends on your perspective. I
mean we could focus on Lactose intolerance, which would make
a recessive pedigree. Or we could the focus on the
flip side, the dominant corollary, lactase persistence and lactose tolerance.
Right? The ability to digest lactose found in many dairy
products like milk and cheese. So let's flip the pedigree
and see what it looks like. So if this is what
a recessive pedigree looks like, when
we focus on lactose intolerance, then let's
flip this pedigree and see what it looks like from the dominant perspective. Now
you're looking at a pedigree of lactose
tolerance from the dominant perspective. Notice that
the shaded symbols of the pedigree have changed quite a bit. They now show
up in every generation of our pedigree, and we see a much higher frequency. In
fact, there are a couple of very distinct
features about a dominant pedigree, compared to a
recessive pedigree. So, which of the following must
be true about a pedigree representing a dominant
trait? Here are four options, and remember that
this time, affected means lactose tolerant not intolerant.
So go ahead and pick any and all that you think apply.